[Música]
gracias a los organizadores por
invitarme estoy muy contenta estar acá
hablando un tema que me apasiona
yo soy sofia soy nutricionista me dedico
a los alimentos pero no desde la mirada
siempre tradicional de como un
nutricionista aborda la alimentación
sino que me apasiona mucho entender los
alimentos dentro del contexto un poco
más amplio es cierto
porque un alimento no solo es lo que
nosotros comemos sino que un alimento se
produce se transporta se crece y eso es
lo que lo que un poco hoy les vengo a
contar
yo trabajé en eeuu y en otros países
mayoritariamente vinculando a la pequeña
producción agrícola con programas
alimentarios infantiles con colegios
pero dedicado también a trabajar mucho
con los pequeños productores y es un
tema que mucho me ha interesado ya y
volvió a chile hace cinco años soy de
santiago pero ahora vivo acá en la
quinta región
y al regresar comencé a observar quiénes
eran los actores que estaban trabajando
en las temáticas que a mí me parecían
interesantes para ver cómo yo podía
sumarme es cierto y tratar de hacer un
aporte
y observé que había mucha evidencia hay
mucha academia trabajando en estos temas
muy interesantes sobre todo desde el
agro
el estado por su parte haciendo
políticas públicas tratando de impulsar
cierto algunas iniciativas y por otro
lado los organismos internacionales que
un poco dan la regulación más de la
región de países de la región pero
sociedad civil había muy poquito no es
que no hubiera pero había muy poquito y
bastante invisibilizado o con muy
segmentado y creo que por ahí podía
haber una oportunidad
la cepal me invitó a dar una conferencia
para contar sobre las políticas públicas
que yo había podido participar en otros
países que eran de circuitos cortos de
comercialización
y había gente súper interesante ahí y en
el café porque por lo general las cosas
interesantes pasan alrededor de los
alimentos cierto en la comida en los
cafés son esa instancia el café no
siempre es como va a salir a hidratarse
sino que para salir a conocer a los
otros personas que espero que pase ahora
cuando terminemos este evento también
y había gente súper interesante
conversamos y todos decíamos bueno cómo
podemos hacer más cosas y elegí bueno
hagamos y así nace actuemos actuamos es
una ong que se lo busca en redes
sociales es actuamos por una corporación
que lo que hacemos es promover cultura
alimentaria ya y para saber qué hacer en
que actuar hicimos un análisis un poco
más profundo del sistema alimentario
chileno
y haciendo este este análisis de lo que
como como chile funciona es un sistema
alimentario hicimos el dibujo
tradicional de lo que la bibliografía
habla de los sistemas alimentarios es
cierto que es cómo se produce si lo
miramos desde el agro ya meylin habló
mucho sobre sobre la pesca después voy a
volver a hablar de eso también pero no
solamente el producto cierto crece y
nosotros lo consumimos sino que el
producto en el proceso requiere mucha
agregación de valor cierto se produce
hay políticas que producen o que
fomentan el incentivo a la producción de
algunos tipos de alimentos versus otros
esto luego pasa a un encadenamiento
comercial cierto por muchos
intermediarios muchas veces y ahí se
sigue agregando más valor hasta que
llegan a un consumidor final que es el
que al final paga por ese valor agregado
cierto
y pensando que somos un país productivo
potencia agroalimentaria hasta hace unos
pocos años atrás era interesante ver lo
que nos sucede a nivel de cifras cierto
en el país
que somos no sé si dieron las noticias
en pocos días atrás somos el segundo
país más obeso de la ocde del abc de
solo nos sigue por delante eeuu que es
como el cierto el paradigma o el dibujo
de la mala alimentación pero estamos muy
cerca de ello chile ha aumentado la
curva obesidad exponencialmente en forma
alarmante
los niños son muy obesos en chile
también no sólo decía sino que sobrepeso
y todas las enfermedades crónicas
asociadas y eso no deja de ser
interesante porque sucede
somos países productivos cierto pero
sólo un 15% de la producción o sea que
sólo un 15% de la población consume las
cantidades de fruta y vegetales que nos
sugieren los organismos internacionales
y uno dice claro porque chile produce y
exporta cierto no comemos lo que
producimos pero las cifras indican de
que efectivamente no se nos exporta a
todo lo que producir sólo se exporta la
mitad de lo que producir entonces qué
pasa con el resto de la producción
chile es un país cierto de costa de mar
llamé el link hablo bastante de nuestro
poco cercanos que somos con nuestra
pesca
y a pesar de que somos un país costero
son un 17% de la población consumen las
recomendaciones de consumo de pescado y
solo gastamos un 8% de nuestro
presupuesto de carne en productos del
mar
sólo un 24% de la población consume las
recomendaciones de legumbres
no sé si si si todos tienen un poco de
la misma cultura alimentaria familiar
pero hace años atrás todos comíamos
mucha legumbre en nuestra dieta
hoy en día bajaron la frecuencia de
consumo y chile por eso dejó de producir
legumbres ahora chile importa legumbres
ya desde canadá mayoritariamente y
cuando se ven las encuestas nacionales
de consumo alimentario observamos que la
gente gasta su plata la plata que gasta
en su canasta alimentaria la gasta en
bebidas gaseosas pan pastas snacks y
carne
es la parte productiva medio consumo
pero también vemos el encadenamiento
cierto cómo llega el producto desde que
se produce hasta que llega al usuario y
también es importante ver cómo crecieron
en forma bastante importante un 70 por
ciento del crecimiento de los otros
mercados en los últimos años versus o en
de medio del crecimiento de los pequeños
mercados de feria el libro los dos
negocios locales
este diagnóstico ya existía no es que
hicimos nada nuevo con esto sino que
solo estoy levantando las cifras
entonces ahora qué hacemos cierto cómo
actuamos y ya la situación está así
y ahí es cuando empezamos a preguntarnos
y les pregunto a ustedes me pregunté yo
también cómo podemos nosotros entonces
aportar desde nuestro sector a revertir
esta situación y creemos que una de las
aristas relevantes es trabajar en el
rescate y valorización del patrimonio
alimentario
estamos en valparaíso mucho se habla del
rescate arquitectónico y cultural cierto
de la ciudad pero poco hablamos del
rescate del patrimonio cultural
gastronómico de la región también
existen productos endémicos
técnicas culinarias que están
perdiéndose productos de la región que
no valorizamos y la oferta gastronómica
por ejemplo del circuito porteño ofrece
productos que son bastante estándar
porque el consumidor lo solicita
entonces viene de nuevo cuál es como
como los sistemas se dinamizan cuando
desde la demanda acierto de yo como
consumidor demando nuevos productos
versus lo estándar y así vamos creando
una nueva oferta de nuevos productos ya
hayáis igual de dinámico los sistemas
alimentarios
en chile los niños consumen
mayoritariamente indican las encuestas 3
frutas
la primera es plátano chileno produce
plátano pero todos los niños como el
plátano
manzana todo el año y naranjas
precisamente porque son las frutas que
son más fáciles de transportar y de
reservar y preservar durante muchos
periodos de tiempo viajan largas
distancias durante dentro del país
entonces tiene que ser una fruta
duradera los niños de del norte tienen
mango pero como en plata cierto
pareciera que hay un algo alguno muy muy
cuerpo en esto
por otra parte hablemos del tomate yo
estaba comentando recién al bad state
sobre eso
comemos tomate todo el año cierto pero
el tomate tiene un periodo estacional
que por lógica es el periodo estacional
donde le da donde tiene más sabor pero
nosotros producimos tomate porque
hacemos una demanda de tomate al mercado
durante todas las épocas del año siendo
que debiéramos preferir son los
productos estacionales cierto idealmente
locales
para también poder pagar un precio más
justo al productor mientras más corta la
cadena de intermediarios mejor es el
pago cierto que lo produce
y mejor el producto que yo recibo a
cambio
algo que hacemos y que lo hacemos con
bastante esfuerzo es precisamente la
educación alimentaria creemos que son
los niños precisamente en quienes
podemos ejercer un cambio más relevante
en términos de hábitos cierto nosotros
ya estamos un poco fritos pero los niños
tienen oportunidades todavía y recordar
que nosotros somos quienes somos los
agentes de cambio si nosotros en el
fondo no promovemos y no incentivamos en
los niños modificaciones de hábitos es
muy difícil que un niño lo vaya a hacer
por iniciativa propia los niños siguen
patrón es cierto y modelamiento que los
adultos les damos así que vamos a
colegios y trabajamos bastante en
promover dentro de los niños la
incorporación de estos nuevos hábitos
alimentarios hay estudios que indican
que un niño que hay que exponerlo al
menos 15 veces a un alimento antes de
saber si este niño tiene aversión al
alimento no alergia me refiero al
rechazo por sabor o sea es propio que
alguien no le pueda gustar un alimento
pero los estudios indican que debemos
intentarlo al menos 15 veces si le damos
15 veces la misma preparación les
aseguro que el rechazo a hacer las
mismas 15 veces pero por qué no probar
distintas texturas distintas formas
formatos y no sino quitar el alimento de
la dieta sino que tratar de entregárselo
de una forma un poco más atractiva
y un poco para reflexionar en base a
esto es cómo es el sistema alimentario
entonces que nosotros soñamos para
nuestro país para nuestra región para
nuestra familia también y vuelvo a lo
mismo en el fondo mientras yo no sé a
quién voy a procurar buscar un productor
local o un producto estacional
y entro dentro de un poco de la lógica
de comprar lo que lo que la gran masa
cierto consume en regularidad
vamos a cada vez evitar el desarrollo de
estos nuevos pequeños mercados que en el
fondo lo que hacen es favorecer el
dinamismo de los sistemas alimentarios
así que la invitación es a que
reflexionemos sobre esto
les invito a seguir las acciones que
nuestra corporación ejecuta y ojalá
entre todos generemos un cambio dentro
del próximo año para que nuestro chile
pueda alimentarse mejor
[Aplausos]
[Música]